good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the University of Southern
California and I'd like to welcome you
to the big data to knowledge guide to
the fundamentals of data science we're
very pleased to have Ravi Midori
speaking with us today
on the subject of Big Data technologies
for biomedical knowledge discovery Robby
Midori is a senior computational
scientist based at the University of
Chicago as well as the Argonne National
Laboratory his research interests are in
large-scale computation and data
management and he leads the globus
genomics project which uses genomics
proteomics and other biomedical
computations on cloud-based and other
hcp platforms
he received an outstanding achievement
award by the NIH in 2007 for the
creation of tools for data analysis and
cancer biology and recently he
participated in the vice president's
cancer moonshot project receiving an
award from the Secretary of the US
Department of Energy we're very pleased
to have Ravi with us this morning
talking on Big Data technologies for
biomedical knowledge discovery and I
encourage you in any questions you have
by the go-to webinar questions
submission system they're located in
your go-to webinar a panel off to the
right on your screen and it will get to
some of those at the end
without further ado allow me to
introduce Ravi Ravi stage is yours thank
you jack thank you for that kind of
direction and thank you and Christopher
for having me here one of the so let me
get started so I kind of wanted to take
some time to to go or why we talked
about big data in life sciences and why
it is important especially because a lot
of the times researchers that work in
this domain
present their results in a manner that
that folks sometimes don't understand
why why investigation and and investment
into this kind of infrastructure
this this kind of analysis is important
and I'll talk a little bit about what
are the some of the tools that we
developed as part of a NIH big data to
knowledge center called BDDs and how we
are developing these tools and how this
to create an impact and to accelerate
the discovery process for an increase
our understanding on genetic basis for
various neurogenic degenerative
disorders and I'll take I'll put a
little bit more emphasis on the data
management and data analysis that these
tools have been able in the context of
big data and kind of end with some of
the results that we have generated using
these data sets and in the end I think
Jack and Krista will come back online to
open up the floor for questions and I'll
be happy to answer those questions so
let me take a few minutes and and kind
of go or why I personally think this is
important as Jack mentioned in his
introduction I'm not I'm a computational
scientist I'm a senior scientist at
University of Chicago and Argonne
National Laboratory
we have supercomputers we have
large-scale high-performance computing
resources here and why do I as a
computer scientist find this kind of big
data analysis in life science is
important and and I have a few slides
where I'll present at a high level why
what we do is is important so I took a
little chart from the from the CDC as
which which every year they they present
were some of the leading causes of death
in the in the US and if you look at the
chart on the left you see that the to
the top two leading
causes of death are heart diseases and
cancer and and my the the kind of the
provocative statement that I want to
make here is that a good portion of
these these deaths could be preventable
or if they were detected early on or if
we understand them better and be able to
see if there are any therapeutics that
that could be developed or that are
already existing that could be reused to
to lower the suffering or to lower the
debts that are caused by these diseases
and with one one of the caveat I want to
say is that with the with the increase
in the understanding of how these
diseases propagate in human body there
is a strong evidence that shows that
there is a there's a pretty good genetic
basis for these diseases so there is
something in in a human gene that that
either causes these diseases or are has
a key to reduce a suffering that that
the folks have to in Europe and they and
they get this is it so I I do understand
that I'm making a sort of a a blanket
argument because each of these heart
disease and cancer research tells us
they are not one disease there are
actually multiple variations of this of
this disease just within the heart
disease there are there are three types
of heart diseases at least at a broader
level there are multiple subtypes of
these types and and maybe folks know bit
more about cancer cancer is in fact a
collection of you know hundred are so
different types of diseases that are
that get in as one umbrella so as you
can see there's a big motivation for why
we have to work in this area
I'll talk a little bit about how this
this leads into big data and what and
how big data analysis and big data
management will help us get more
understanding about how this how we
could make a dent at these in these
disease areas so this is a paper that
was published in Nature and the authors
make a statement and marker dr. Rubin is
at Cardinal Medical College in New York
and they say that they found out after a
lot of data analysis that 90% of people
who are diagnosed with a type of cancer
are or do carry a genetic variation of
mutation that that makes this patient's
responsive to a known drug so let me
kind of take a minute to let the sink in
so 90% of people who are suffering from
cancer that are out there carry a
genetic mutation that makes these people
respond to a known drug so we could be
helping them if we know what mutation is
these people carry and finding out what
mutation that that people who are
diagnosed with cancer carry I argue is a
big data analysis problem and and this
is the tool these are some of the tools
that we developed to make it easy for
for us to discover the mutations that
these patients carry and that may lead
to lead to prescribing a drug that would
that would help them a little bit so
that that's in cancer and if you move to
the cardiovascular disease this is a new
study that was published in a New
England Journal of Medicine where they
they have done a pretty comprehensive
study of over 55,000 participants in
which they they looked into the way
yes factors that that make people
susceptible to different heart diseases
and and you know if you look at this
paper it's a it's pretty clear that you
know lifestyle choices can do definitely
have the power to reduce your genetic
risk to these diseases but the but in
the context of the stock the point I'm
trying to make here is that in the
cardiovascular disease area there is
there's been a lot of signs that that
helped discover the the genetic risk
factors that may make a person more
susceptible to the coronary heart
diseases so as you can see in that in
the top two killers in the in the US the
cancer and heart diseases we we see that
increase in in our understanding of how
various factors genetic factors
lifestyle factors affect these diseases
would help us create therapeutics or
take existing drugs and and by being
able to discover what would be effective
for a particular subject we can actually
do a a great deal of good to this to
folks who are suffering or who might be
suffering from this disease this this
particular thinking is often termed as
precision medicine where you understand
individual risk profile and you tailor
their treatment that to match their
genetic and and their and their other
lifestyle factors that fit that profile
so we so Nancy Cox she is she
the president of the American Society of
Human Genetics and a longtime
collaborator for for me she's one of the
things that she says is that in order to
find a single mutation are a bunch of
mutations or genetic variants that may
make a person more susceptible to cancer
or coronary heart diseases finding those
mutations are finding those genetic
variants is is akin to finding a needle
in a haystack
meaning that you're essentially sifting
through a lot of data to find this one
particular data that or evidence that
may that may throw more light into into
understanding a person's susceptibility
or our sort of factors that may affect
that may have affected this particular
person's disease onset so one of the
things that folks in in this area of
science do is in order to find this
needle in a haystack people typically
build their own infrastructure they they
build huge computing forms called
private clusters and that that take a
lot of time and money to build so in in
some sense
folks are building their their own
haystacks assualt sorting machine so one
of the things that we argue in this
presentation is that by by building your
own infrastructure by by building your
own needle haystack sorting machine
you're essentially spending valuable
time and and money in in creating
infrastructure where our goal in the
BBBS project is to build services and
tools that will hopefully
prevent you or a researcher to build
their own infrastructure and their own
tools to find these needles in a
haystack
so these needles are or could be a a
protein that you would be able to find
using large-scale for yarmulkes analysis
or these needles could be a genetic
marker that you could find using
large-scale genomics analysis and in
this particular talk I'll take an
example of of an hypothesis that our
colleagues in this project from the
Institute for systems biology in Seattle
have made which is to understand or to
get better and standing of transcript
transcript transcription regulate
refractors that effect a gene to express
itself more so that once we understand
this transcriptional factors better
we'll be able to build a network of them
that will help shed more light in in
diseases like Alzheimer's and others so
one of the things that I also want to
emphasize is that then the finding
needle in a haystack analogy is is
getting a little bit more and more
appropriate if you look at the growth in
in how how much the data that we are
collecting in in with how much genetic
data we are collecting so this this
little graph is a it's kind of has
become a must show in all of the big
data talks because it kind of shows how
the genetic data is growing I keep
thinking about a day when I can present
a talk without having to show this slide
because it's kind of a little scary and
depressing because you know we are no
ways equipped to to kind of handle the
data that that we are expected to
generate in in sequencing DNA as you can
say
one of the things that people say is
that you know we were collecting more
data then then we have available storage
in the world but but but anyway so this
is a this is a chart that shows how how
much of the genetic data is growing and
this is a little map that I put together
to show that these are locations in the
world where that the genetic sequencers
are being are operational and are
generating data so you might think that
you know all of the data that is that in
that earth that is being generated in
genetics is is us-centric or may be
generated at one place but in fact it's
not it's there are all of these machines
the sequencing machines that are
distributed geographically across the
world and all of them are generating
data so one of the new sequencing
machines that Illumina has released has
a potential to generate a terabyte of
data every day so if we can multiply
that with the numbers here you can see
how we are at increased rate at which we
can we can generate that a data so the
graph that I showed in the earlier slide
in fact could be much more could have a
bigger slope or it could be trending we
could be training there much faster so
if if you look at you know why this
finding the needles in a haystack or why
finding insights in big data is a
challenge you could see we looked at
this we we analyzed this these
challenges these challenge we analyzed
these challenges for for a long time
this has been our area of research for
over 20 years now and when we looked at
some of the fundamental challenges that
the researchers face in in doing this
kind of research is there are two sets
of challenges one is in the
area of data management and access
challenges in in genomics in in
proteomics in a lot of research that
where people are trying to find this
proverbial needles data that they need
or they're generating is it's typically
distributed across the world so if you
take the example of genetics data there
are reference datasets that that are
being used that are located in in
different places and and sequencing
centers where that are generating this
data for researchers that I showed in
the previous slide they are shipping
hard drives are full of genetics data to
to researchers and it's a it's a very
[Music]
inefficient way of moving data because
if you try to move a large data set
using using Carrick's or one of the
older internet protocols called FTP or
HTTP you would realize that it will this
process takes multiple days to to move
the data and researchers typically rely
on sharing data with each other when
they collaborate and this these
collaborations and sharing typically
happens using by putting a webserver and
putting the data there and and again
these are very inefficient way of doing
sharing data with your collaborators
because the reason why people generate
data is the primary reason is they want
to analyze this data and when they have
to analyze the data it could be using a
cloud computing resource or it could be
using a supercomputer or typically what
happens as researchers have to move the
data again into a local compute
capability so as you can see there's a
lot of movement of data and and you
could you could say that Oh FedEx is
very good at moving data I work with
researcher who got their sequencing done
in China and their FedEx who fell X
their hard drive full of genomics data
and it got stuck in customs because they
they couldn't really they wanted to test
it to make sure it passed through so it
takes a long time for people to get data
so once you have the data you could see
the next set of challenges is in the
analysis of this data because that's
where you get the insights that you are
looking for and people typically resort
to writing shell scripts and and
arguably these are people who are
computationally sophisticated and they
are writing good shell scripts to do
their analysis but if you look at these
shell scripts they are a lot of there's
a lot of manual process in this in this
analysis and whenever you have manual
process you know that it could be made
more efficient so if you look at the the
analysis side what people do is they
typically manually move all the data to
where they could do the analysis they
install all the tools they they do
sequentially run this analysis on their
computers and one of the main things
that this one of the main disadvantages
for this is that because they are done
by an individual or a team they're how
to reproduce their this the knowledge
that is gained is is kind of lost or be
are just available in that group so
oftentimes the shell scripts are like
toothbrushes you can't share
toothbrushes and you can share shell
scripts so it's it's it's very simple
analogy so the the the shell scripts and
the data management manually moving data
and manually making this data available
to your collaborators and doing the
analysis
it's a cumbersome process that often
leads to science that is not
reproducible when science does is not
reproducible it makes it harder for
somebody to validate your your findings
and build upon those findings so what
that means is that you know if I am a
researcher and I want to leverage
somebody else's work and I want to build
on top of it I can do that because
because the tools that you've used are
making this this into a process that is
not reliability purchasable so within
the BBBS
so this is a little graphic that kind of
shows why you know having Big Data are
generating big data may be very
overwhelming for researcher to do the
analysis what we want to do is we want
to harness the power of Big Data and to
leave that power into into ideas and do
validation into new findings so my my
goal here today is to show you how in
the BDDs Center we are generating these
tools that allows you to harness the
power of big data in a way that it
doesn't overwhelm you and in a way that
this this power could lead to ideas and
discoveries so in the in our Center our
our guiding principle is to let the data
lead you to the discoveries so we know
that there's been a lot of effort and
time and resources spent in generating a
lot of data resources and I'll talk a
little bit about some of these data
resources and how big they are but
they're but it's not enough to just
generate the data it's also important to
to harness this data in a way that it is
reproducible in a way and deliver and
generate results so in the in BDDs we
generate we created a platform that
allows you to that allows researchers to
manage the data more efficiently that
allows them to create
analysis pipelines and published them in
a way that the whole processes are
producible we created ways we created
tools that enables this discovery
process in a reproducible manner so
these are some of the some of the tools
that we developed and I'll talk a little
bit about each one of them with an
emphasis on on one particular scientific
hypothesis that we will be validated
so the BDDs platform as I mentioned
before has has tools in two different
categories one is in the data management
category that makes it easy for for
researchers to integrate datasets from
genomics proteomics and an image
datasets in an end-to-end standard
format so that you can exchange these
datasets with your collaborators with
enough metadata so they can know exactly
where this data is coming from and what
this data contains in it we created
tools and services that allows
researchers to create reusable processes
and catalogs to to results catalogs of
data for for researchers to discover
what results have been created we
created interfaces so for researchers to
create easily create cohorts so for
example you want to say you know I want
to do this analysis on all the patients
that have this particular genetic marker
or all the patients that are diagnosed
with lung cancer that that haven't
smoked in their life so you are you we
created into tools that allows you to
create these codes and and finally we we
created and operate this these services
that makes it easy for you to rapidly
analyze these data sets on on public
cloud computing resources on and
high-performance computing resources the
key is to make these analysis pipelines
be
reproducible on-demand so others can
build on top of these these pipelines
without having to recreate them so I so
this is some of the one of the
hypotheses that we worked on which is to
get better understanding of what are the
genetic susceptibility low sign for
Alzheimer's disease and and there's some
meta analysis that's been done over for
74,000 individuals and we really once we
started looking at the data we realize
how little we really know and there's
been a lot of literature on this
transcriptomic regulatory factors that
do affect the genetic expression so we
wanted to understand how how much this
this transcriptomic factors how how much
more insight that these factors can
provide us in in the onset of
Alzheimer's so our colleagues that is we
have created a a method called trina
which which tries to create a network
out of this transcriptomic regulatory
factors that helps you better reason why
some of this factors to have a have an
impact on also emerge disease and in one
of the ideas is to create a model for
every gene that you identify in this in
this analysis and and use the
transcriptomic regulated factors to
better explain why you see this the
onset of these diseases in these
subjects so this this hypothesis has
resulted in a very comprehensive a
flowchart that describes various data
sets and various analysis that you we
need to perform in order to get the
insight that we are talking about this
pipeline was so complicated that it it
didn't fit into
a single slide even though I spent a
considerable amount of time as you can
see you saw this this important factor a
box is kind of lost but but the idea
here is that we have a series of
analysis pipelines that we need to
develop and we have a few data sets that
are publicly available that are
generated by the nih including the
encode data set a road map data set that
have all of the raw data that that we
need to analyze in order to generate
these regulatory networks that better
explain the onset of Alzheimer's in the
in the in the subjects that I mentioned
before so this is a a a a a pipeline a
set of analysis that we developed and we
created a new tool called Treena which
takes results from all of these analysis
and gives you a more evidence on our
better explanation for for various
genetic factors or the proverbial
needles in a haystack
it we try to find using using these
these these techniques so I I divided
this into a few few few categories and
data discovery is so as I described in
in one of the slides before where we
divided this problem into a set of
categories one category is discovery
right so as I mentioned there are a lot
of existing NIH funded databases that
have the data that we need to do this
analysis and one of those datasets is is
called encode and encode is a publicly
available data set which is an
encyclopedia of DNA elements it has a
publicly available interface a web
portal that you can go and query for the
data and as you can see it has a
a lot of tissue samples that that we
need to do this analysis one of the
first things we did in order to make it
easy to for us to create this portable
data bags is by we call this tool a PD
bag which is essentially as you can as I
mentioned before there are multiple
pipelines in this in this discovery
process and we want to make it easy for
us to move the data from one analysis to
one platform to the next platform and in
order for us to do that we had to create
a mechanism to make it easy for us to
portably move datasets with metadata so
that for every pipeline we don't have to
recreate the datasets and and regenerate
them in order for us through the
analysis so we haven't so one of the
things that we did was we we looked at
how Library of Congress handles data
archiving and data data sharing and we
looked at a product specification called
baguette and we extended that
specification to Big Data and we created
a beedi back specification that allows
you to create a portable data format
which is also an acronym for PDF to for
big data so so that when we when we
query encode and we generate a huge data
set that we want to do the analysis on
we do so as a beedi bag and we do send
this big data bags into multiple
analysis routines so we have enough
metadata that will lead to the free
reproducibility and reusability of of
these data sets so the beauty bag is
pretty simple concept it has its set of
raw data sets
cribes what data this bag is carrying
and more and and the most important part
of this is it has a checksum which is a
computer science speak of fingerprint
right so a checksum is very unique
identifier that that that allows a
receiver to validate that they have
received the data without any corruption
so the beauty bag contains this a
portable format in which you could you
could take data from once or one
platform to another and hope that
there's that other platform can
understand and process the data so we
created a service on top of in code so
we can create this beauty bags so encode
has a few tissue samples so for example
we won't analyze lung tissue we can
write a query to encode and it would
generate a beauty bag full of lung
tissues data from lung tissue that we
can do the analysis on so now we have
two things we have a bag full of data
that has enough metadata associated with
it we have a way to query and generate
this bag now we move to generating
identifier for this bag the reason why
these identifiers are important is that
these are your your these are the things
that you're recording so that you could
pop when you publish your results or
your pipeline there are identifiers that
allow somebody to validate that yes this
exists and this is expected this is as
this research team is claiming it to be
so we created a service that allows you
to to create this identifiers and every
data item that you have seen in this
huge pipeline that I showed before has
an identifier assigned to it and this is
a digital identifier you can reserve you
can reference it you can share it with
your collaborators and
you can resolve it this makes a very
this makes it very easy for you to share
big datasets when you have a minimal
identifiers you just send that mean ID
to your collaborator and they can
resolve this solves a problem that I
mentioned before where you're setting up
an FTP server or or some other format to
make it easy for you to to share data so
this shows how you can resolve a minimal
identifiers and more importantly it
shows the metadata that is identified
that is available with this identifier
so it has a unique identifier we used
something called arc to generate this it
shows when this bag is created it shows
who created it and this identifier next
to Kyle has what is called an orchid
which is a research identifier it
uniquely identifies Kyle as a researcher
at University of Chicago it provides a
checksum and it provides a location in
which you can download this bag right
now this bag is located on Amazon and
you could you could use Amazon data
access mechanisms to retrieve this bag
so in order to make it easy for
researchers we generated a lot of tools
to to generate these identifiers so now
that we have the back we have the
identifier that uniquely identifies that
bag we now we we move to the next level
of how do we move this data and how do
we reliably share this these bags with
researchers one of the challenges that
we have in Big Data is the bag that we
generated was around 23 terabytes of
data right so it's not it's not small
enough for you to carry your own in a
USB stick it's not small enough for you
to download it in FTP server
we tried and it took us more than a few
weeks and the transfer never succeeded
because these are inherently unreliable
ways of moving data so we build a
service that makes it easy for you to
manage share and transfer your datasets
it's called Globus Globus as
data transfer data management service
that makes it easy for researchers to
move data big data easily without having
to become experts in UNIX or it also
makes it easy for researchers to share
data sets with each other reliably in
the later part of the talk I'll talk
about some of the additional services we
built where researchers can publish
their their results and others can
discover them using some of the some of
the data management services we created
and operate so as I said before Globus
makes it easy for for researchers to to
do large-scale data transfers it
provides secure access with a
multi-tiered security model and one of
the important things that we've done is
we we improved the performance at which
you can move data so you can move a lot
of data really quickly so this is a sort
of a graphic that shows the improved
performance and comparison with existing
data streams with existing data
protocols on how quickly you can move
data so as you can see Groody FTP which
is a protocol that we use to move data
in lowers all performs a traditional
data transfer protocols so this is a an
interface for searching this is a Big
Data data repository where researchers
can publish their datasets bit metadata
and others can look into it and discover
them and when I talk about the the
tweener pipeline I'll show how we have
leveraged all of these services to how
we leverage Globus transfer to move the
the raw data from encode into Amazon
Cloud storage and how we were able to
leverage our analysis service to run
large-scale analysis how we generated
mean IDs for them and how we generated
results and publish them
these data repositories for for others
to to find them so this is a process in
which somebody would publish their data
sets into the global publication service
so Globus is a is pretty widely used
across a research enterprise 190
petabytes of data have been moved with
20 billion the files that were processed
it has over 50,000 registered users and
enjoys a lot of uptime because we run
this as a production quality service
that the researchers can depend on for
managing their big data so let's move to
the how now that we figured out a way to
to generate unique identifiers so
generate portable data formats for for
this raw and code data sets all of this
is in is in support to to find those
needles in a haystack so we built a
service called
Globus genomics that that combines
global data management and and analysis
on cloud using using a tool called
galaxy so using this this service
researchers can get the the data bags
that they have generated from from
encode service they can build a scalable
analysis pipeline that runs on on cloud
computing resources one of the important
innovations that we've done is that by
by understanding the computational
capabilities of these tools we were able
to schedule these analysis to be run on
on cloud resources at a very small price
using spot market so that you could do
large-scale big data analysis without
having to pay a lot of dollars for
compute so how do we kind of so now that
you have seen all of these building
blocks of doing big data analysis how
we bring them all to bear for evaluating
this one hypothesis that I presented
before so we take we created a small
chart that explains how we've done it so
we pre created a interface that will
allow researchers to query the encode
data set created a bag and use that bag
to send that to the the global genomic
service that I showed before and the
service will will allow researchers to
do assemble a pipeline analysis that
will take this beauty bag do the
analysis at scale on cloud computing
Souls and generate a bag of results that
show how these transcriptomic regulator
networks are affecting various various
genetic loci for Alzheimer's disease and
we take these networks and we publish
them in a publication service and we
take the raw data that that we generate
and publish them into the de River
service that that you know certain
California manages so others can
discover them query them easily so just
to remind you this is a pipeline that we
are attempting to build use in the in
the global genomic service and we ended
up creating one which takes this is the
pipeline in the bottom half of the
picture and it takes a mean ID as an
input the mean ID is the ID for the BD
bag that we have generated from the
encode data repository so this mean ID
could represent all of the raw data sets
for a particular organ that a researcher
is interested in and we run this
analysis at scale and we generate their
transcriptomic regulatory Network model
that will help researchers to get better
understanding of how how this genetic
loss I factor in in the onset of
Alzheimer's so this is how we run it at
scale on all of the datasets and I have
a slide that shows the scale at
to run it so once we have these results
we can essentially do we generated a bag
of results so this bag is created by a
colleague of mine at University of
Chicago the as you as I've shown before
the the bag of raw input was generated
by Kyle but the bag of results is
created by Alex what what the beedi bag
allows you to do is that multiple
collaborators can work and be able to
exchange data sets with ease with each
other with enough metadata so this
particular bag refers to a lymphoblast
cell but the footprinting new results
from those that transcriptomic regulator
networks for that particular tissue we
also built a catalog that makes it easy
for researchers to query these results
so for example with within encode we
have we have generated results for 2062
types and this result spans from genetic
data sets for Yamaka sets but if a
researcher is trying to find or trying
to narrow down a particular area of
interest it's often hard for them to to
sift through thousands of files in order
to find that data we built a catalog
called a river that catalogs using the
metadata of all of these years hats
catalogs all the data and provides a
nice and easy to use interface that
allows researchers to query for
particular aspects of the data and do
further downstream analysis on this data
I talked about the data repository
before this is another mechanism for how
you can publish the findings of a
research paper and if somebody is
reading your paper they can go to the we
will provide the links to the repository
they can go to this repository - just to
find the results that that helps them to
build on your research or on your
findings
so in conclusion you know with this
particular analysis we there are
couldn't be six tissue types but they
correspond to 262 samples and the total
amount of data we have analyzed is
around 2.5 terabyte it's and we created
a lot of tools and high performance
computing workflows that ran at scale on
on Amazon Cloud resources and and the
important thing in this slide is that we
created 106 publicly available databases
that provide this regulated networks for
all of the tissue samples that are
available in in encode this will help
others to build on using these databases
you know without recreating them so in
conclusion in the the BDDs Center is
it's comprised of experts in in various
life sciences research and computer
science and our goal is to provide a
streamlined approach for big data
management aggregation manipulation
integration and modeling of our various
biological systems across spatial star
under temporal scales so thank you for
for taking time and added anything today
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions that you may have thank you so
much Robbie that was a really great
overview of a very interesting ecosystem
for being able to manage manipulate and
process large scale biomedical data I
encourage everybody who's listening to
submit a question again using the
GoToWebinar question submission system
in the meantime Robbie you mentioned
something about the bags the beady bags
system and I'm curious how the bag
system differentiates itself from just
like a classic kind of tar file and if
if those are published someplace and
they act as kind of a centralized thing
what happens if somebody updates those
files and then all of a sudden the the
data that I
was expecting is now different how is
that documented and reported back to the
end-users yeah it's a great question so
one of the important difference between
is a tar file and and a bag is that that
the back in addition to containing the
list of the raw data sets
it also contains check sums for all of
those data sets and they check sum for
the bag itself so for example if you
change the file or if you change the
collection that that the bag refers to
that checksums don't match anymore
so if somebody were to download a tar
file today and the the generator of the
tar file changed that to a different
added or deleted some data in that tar
file if you download it tomorrow there's
no way of you know you could you could
look at both the tower files and they
would name they would be the same but
with including when you include the
checksum between the tar file and you
can say that yes this file has changed
since the last time I touched so that's
one big differentiator between a bag and
a tar file and the second thing is BD
bag also has a mean ID associated with
it this is a unique identifier that has
more metadata associated with it in
terms of who created this bag and where
is this pag located and when was is
created and the checksum that that had
that for the data that was in that bag
which makes it a lot more powerful when
you were when you care about produce
ability of research also are there any
dependencies on the type of workflow
engine that's being deployed so I mean
you mentioned galaxy obviously which is
widely popular for genetics and for
other things I'm curious if other
workflow engines are suitable here and
if you can describe anything that's been
done with other systems yeah no that's a
great question so I so know
baby bag tools and the format is it's
not dependent on one workflow it's
pretty so we have work done to make the
Lonni pipeline which is a very popular
tool to do large-scale image analysis
they have used the beauty bag format and
tools to to exchange large image
datasets so none of the so it's not just
constrained to a data a tool or
technology it is pretty general purpose
tool that's great
do you send in any questions that you
might have folks one other thing I was
curious about is where are these jobs
run I mean I presume that you know that
it University of Chicago and at Argonne
you've got giant computers you know
warehouses full of computers where this
stuff can run are these the types of
things which can be deployed to other
institutions or is there is it solely
dependent upon your cluster or could it
run on my you know my Amazon account or
my Google cloud accounts yeah so as I
mentioned one of the things that we've
done with in the in the in our work is
you know we realized that no we don't
want to build a haystack sorting machine
for everybody I mean to some extent
everybody if everybody decides to build
their own machine then it makes a it
takes a long time to do science so all
of this tools Global's and and global
tsunamis that all services that are
running on Amazon and and if you want to
run it on your own Alex Globus on a
global tsunami you can run it in your
Amazon account so there is there's some
operational tools that we built to make
the services reliable and make them run
at scale on public cloud computing
resources and where can we find these
resources if we're
interested in investigating them
ourselves I should have put a link for
the BT two BDDs
tools of webpage maybe I can maybe you
can put it and I should have put it in
my slides but bd2k BDDs Center website
has a tool section where you can find
all the tools and the github
repositories where they're located
fantastic and where can we find like
Globus and Globus tools Globalstar argh
is it's the website and I just this is
sort of a little bit of a different
question in the context I mean we have
these webinars in the context of
biomedical data science but I'm curious
if it through Globus and through other
initiatives that you guys are involved
with there at the University of Chicago
and with with Argonne it's on you must
be dealing with other scientific data
types whether it's particle physics or
astrophysics or something else they
generate a massive scale data I'm
curious if do you have any lessons
learned from those data types or those
scientific domains which are helpful as
biomedical scientists deal with ever
increasingly large data sets yeah
definitely I mean so so one of the great
things of working at Argonne and
University of Chicago is that you know
there are a lot of great scientists that
happened here and traditionally we have
worked very closely with with the Large
Hadron Collider on particle physics on
discovery of expose on and a lot of the
lessons learned in big data management
in high energy physics and on earthquake
sciences and climate modeling those are
those were sort of the lessons that have
resulted in their tools and services
that we built you know in in it's
interesting you you say so in the
hydrogen physics there is one central
location in CERN where big data is being
you know this particle collider is
generating petabytes of data and one of
the early things that they have done is
every institution in the world that is
doing a research in in particle physics
started building their own
infrastructure and quickly realize that
there's no way they can they can host
all the data they need they can run all
the compute they need they created what
is called the LHC grid which is a
distributed multi tier model that has
streamlined managing data moving data to
multiple centers across the world and
distributing the compute that is
required to gain the insights if you
have been following the the press lately
we were involved in in building
infrastructure for LIGO which was in
impress recently for discovering
gravitational waves and this is a
similar approach that the gravitational
physicists have taken in order to gain
the insights from the data they're
generating I realize you know life
sciences they're still you know in the
in the grand scale of big data sciences
life sciences is sort of a newcomer
especially with the advent of next-gen
sequencing and large-scale you know MRI
machines that generate that are
generating a lot more data but that's
this is expertise that we we gathered
from working and work with various other
domains and we think it has a lot of
impact and use in the life sciences - we
don't have to relearn every lesson that
is learned across all the other domains
just because we have a not invented here
attitude you know we our goal is to sort
of bring some of the lessons that we
learn from other domains to bring to
bear to accelerate the discovery process
in life sciences mostly because the
discoveries that we may be making life
sciences
a great impact in human health and that
makes it very personal oh absolutely I
think you know the holy grail of a
large-scale data science for biomedicine
is to do something like discover a Higgs
boson or you know find gravitational
waves or you know have some big results
that could not have existed unless we
had marshaled massive amounts of data
and we figured out how to leverage
large-scale computing move data only
when needed
apply workflow technologies and to be
able to model things such that we can
make those kinds of discoveries that
would be a wonderful outcome and I think
what you've described here looks like
we're well down the path of getting
towards that at that special day with
something like that happens and we cure
cancer or you know we get some insight
into disease or diabetes or or something
else so thank you for sharing this
exciting ecosystem for discovery science
Ravi really appreciated and with that
we've kind of reached the end of our
hour and I want to thank everyone for
for tuning in and please look forward to
future speakers and our fundamentals to
the guy sorry bd2k guy to the
fundamentals of data science and we'll
see you next time
thank you everyone and thank you Robbie
thank you